MVP OF THE GAME.
>> FIRST THINGS FIRST, LET'S GO
TO THE COURT AND JIM NANTZ.
>> ALL RIGHT, E.J., LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, WE ARE HERE WITH THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONS THE KANSAS
JAYHAWKS.
AND IT'S TIME TO RECEIVE THE
CHAMPIONSHIP TROPHY, CHAIRMAN
TOM BRUNETTE, PRESIDENT, WILL
YOU PLEASE PRESENT THE TROPHY TO
COACH BILL SELF.
>> FIRST OF ALL, LET'S THANK THE
CITY OF NEW ORLEANS FOR HOSTING
A WONDERFUL TOURNAMENT AND
BRINGING US ALL BACK TOGETHER
AGAIN AND SECOND OF ALL, THE
FANS THE FANS HERE HAVE BEEN
AMAZING.
THE UNIVERSITY OF KANSAS FAN
BASE HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARY, WE
ARE SO EXCITED FOR YOU.
AND HERE TO PRESENT THE TROPHY
IS THE HEAD OF THE BASKETBALL
COMMITTEE, TO COACH SELF AND THE
KANSAS CITY JAYHAWKS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF KANSAS CITY
JAYHAWKS.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, BEAUTIFUL
JOB ON BEHALF OF THE BASKETBALL
COMMITTEE, CONGRATS.
>> WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE RIGHT
HERE?
>> WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
>> THANKS.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, HEY,
B
BACK UP A LITTLE BIT.
HEY, EASY, GET BACK.
>> ALL RIGHT, REMY, GOOD JOB.
COACH, EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW,
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO THE TEAM AT
HALFTIME WHEN YOU WERE DOWN 15?
>> I REALLY DIDN'T SAY MUCH, WE
WERE DISAPPOINTED IN HOW WE
PLAYED THE FIRST HALF.
CAROLINA WAS OBVIOUSLY THE MUCH
BETTER TEAM AND THIS TEAM HAS
BEEN DOWN BEFORE.
AND YOU KNOW, I TOLD HIM AT
HALFTIME, WOULD YOU RATHER BE
DOWN 15 WITH 20 LEFT OR DOWN
NINE WITH TWO LEFT, BECAUSE THAT
WAS WHAT HAPPENED IN 2008 AND
THEY SAID, LET'S TAKE 15.
SO WE PLAYED OFF OF THAT.
>> I THOUGHT ABOUT YOUR TEAM
TONIGHT, ABOUT WHAT YOU GUYS DID
IN THE REGIONAL FINAL.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE A BIG DEFICIT.
YOU TURN TODAY SWITCH IN MIAMI,
AND IT WAS SIMILAR TO WHAT IT
WAS TONIGHT.
>> WE DIDN'T PLAY WELL IN THE
FIRST HALF AGAINST MIAMI, BUT WE
WERE LIGHTS THOUGHT THE SECOND
HALF AND TONIGHT, WE LABORED THE
SECOND HALF.
THE KIDS COMPETED, WE STILL
DIDN'T MAKE FREE THROWS AND IT'S
AS GOOD DEFENSIVELY AS A TEAM WE
CAN PLAY IN THE SECOND HALF.
>> BROWN CAME UP BIG AND I HATE
TO ISOLATE PLAYERS LIKE
McCORMACK, AND DAVID YOU HIT BIG
SHOTS.
THAT WAS HUGE TOO.
WASN'T IT?
>> YEAH, WE HAD SOME REALLY GOOD
POSSESSIONS TO LAY.
WE POSTED CB A COUPLE OF TIMES
AND EVERYBODY CONTRIBUTED.
EVERYBODY PLAYED WELL.
BUT, WE, WHEN WE HAD TO HAVE A
BASKET, WE WENT TO BIG DAVE AND
HE DELIVERED.
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU TO
HAVE NOW, A SECOND NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP, YOU ARE THE FIRST
KANSAS COACH IN HISTORY, TO HAVE
MULTIPLE NATIONAL TITLES.
THE FIRST EVER.
YOU HAVE DONE THAT NOW.
YOU SAID THAT YOU WANTED MORE IN
A PRESS CONFERENCE THIS WEEK.
AND YOU HAVE IT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
>> WELL, IT MEANS THAT KANSAS
HAS WON A FOURTH NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP IS WHAT IT MEANS
AND IT'S GREAT FOR THE KIDS.
IT'S ESPECIALLY SPECIAL FOR MY
FAMILY THIS YEAR BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, WE LOST OUR FATHER TWO
MONTHS AGO, SO, WE HAD A LOT TO
PLAY FOR.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, COACH.
I KNOW HOW MUCH THIS ONE MEANT
IN YOUR HEART.
I KNOW IT DID.
WELL DONE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> WHOA.
ALL RIGHT.
CHRISTIAN, QUICK WORD.
I'M LOOKING FOR OCHAI ALSO.
HOW ABOUT THE HAND YOU HAD UP AT
THE LAST SHOT OF THE GAME WITH
THE ATTEMPT TO TIE.
>> HE GOT A GOOD LOOK, BUT FELT
GOOD WHEN HE MISSED.
>> YOUR TEAMMATE HERE, IT COULD
HAVE GONE TO ANY ONE OF THE GUY
ON THE JAYHAWKS.
OCHAI YOU HAVE BEEN NAMED THE
MOST OUTSTANDING PLAYER OF THE
FINAL FOUR, CONGRATULATIONS.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
MAN, IT'S A SPECIAL GROUP OF
GUYS.
WE ARE GOING DOWN IN HISTORY,
ALL I HAVE TO SAY IS ROCK CHALK,
BABY!
YOU GUYS, I REALIZED WITH THIS,
THIS IS THE BIGGEST COME BACK IN
THE HISTORY OF THE CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME.
YOU GUYS WILL FOREVER HAVE THAT
CLAIM AS THE COMEBACK KIDS HOW
DID YOU DO IT?
>> ANOTHER HISTORY TONIGHT.
WE LOCKED IN AS A FAMILY AS A
TEAM.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE OVER COME THE ODDS AND
ADVERSITY, WE ARE BUILT FOR
THIS.
THERE'S ONE SHINING MOMENT.
YOU ARE THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONS.
THE KANSAS JAYHAWKS, THE MEMORY
FINAL FOUR IS THE O